AUSTIN GROSSMAN: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming out
on pre-Labor Day day.
I'm Austin Grossman.
I wrote a novel, "Crooked."
And we're going
to talk about that
and we're going to talk
about Richard Nixon
and what he means.
Here's my quick bio.
I started out in the
'90s writing video games
and designing video games.
Worked on "Ultima Underworld,"
I worked on "System Shock,"
worked on "Deus Ex."
Just doing the ones you
recognize, not the failures.
I worked on "Epic
Mickey" and then
most recently, the
first "Dishonored" game
and the second "Dishonored"
game-- I keep forgetting that's
public-- with Arkane Studios.
I went to grad school for
English literature, which
is very, very useful on the
job market, it turned out.
And I started writing novels.
I wrote a first novel
called "Soon I Will Be
Invincible" about a
supervillain, which
I published at the age of 37.
So I was not one of
your little prodigies.
And then I published a
second novel called "You"
about working in the
video game industry
and what video games mean.
And now, I wrote this
book about Richard Nixon.
You'll notice the books are
totally different from one
another, which is what we
call "not building a brand"
in the book trade.
So I'm going to-- yes.
I'm going to read a little bit
from the beginning of the book
and then we'll talk about Nixon.
And then I'll read a little
bit from the end of the book.
So this is Chapter 1.
And to set the scene,
this is the night
of the Watergate break-in.
This is Nixon sitting
around in the Oval Office,
waiting to hear what's happening
over at the Watergate Hotel.
"The Oval Office always
smelled of cigarette smoke,
of medical disinfectant, and
a faint undercurrent of sage.
I just hope no one ever puts the
great seal under a black light.
Near the end, we had to steam
clean it after each new moon.
The walls were a pale yellow and
on summer evenings like this,
the flags hung limp, like
so much damp laundry.
It's June 1972.
There was nothing to do but
wait, all night if I had to,
looking out at the
black Washington, DC sky
and my own reflection in the
window, an old man's reflection
now.
I couldn't help sweating in the
June heat, my shirt and wool
jacket sticking to my back.
It was always remarked that
I never took it off publicly.
I don't like to come
across as too informal.
That, and there was some
custom tailoring in there
that it wouldn't do
for people to see,
a hidden pocket that
held a small caliber
revolver with a speed loader.
Regular bullets, no
silver-plated nonsense.
My insurance policy,
along with a vellum scroll
held to my thin, pale, old
man's calf with a rubber band."
Did I mention that the
other half of this book
is about a Lovecraftian
supernatural conspiracy?
Well, it is.
This is my
Lovecraft-Nixon mashup.
"I lit a cigarette.
Pat would be asleep by now.
No one awake but me and
the security guards.
Franklin D. Roosevelt built
the modern version of the Oval
Office in the 1930s.
At this hour, it can
feel like a time machine,
going back to the barren
swampland that once was here,
square miles of muck
and still black water.
In November 1620, 500 miles to
the north, 102 British settlers
arrived and started dying.
Half of them went
almost immediately,
from diseases caught
during the journey,
coupled with no food
and a killing winter.
Only four adult women
survived that first year
in the Plymouth colony, fugitive
Protestant mystics, Tillies
and Martins and Chiltons.
They huddled together
in half-built log halls,
reading by firelight on the
edge of a frozen continent
next to a dark forest
that stretched westward,
all the way to the Mississippi.
They couldn't even
bury their dead.
Outside, the snow had
fallen six feet deep,
and there were moving
shapes in the night.
They were 53 people
without a country,
watching one another die until
one of them-- we will never
know who-- walked
out into the darkness
to do what none of
the others would.
The colony at Roanoke had died.
Plymouth would live.
I stubbed out the cigarette
and took off my jacket.
It was time for
me to do my part.
I closed the blinds, knelt
down, and pulled back
the carpeting to reveal the
greater seal of the office.
I rolled up my left sleeve
and cut twice with a dagger,
as prescribed, to release the
blood of the democratically
elected, the duly
sworn and consecrated.
I began to chant.
These were not the duties
of the US presidency
as I had once conceived of them.
But really, ask yourself
if everything in your life
is the way they told
you it would be.
I speak the words,
light the incense,
and try to clear my mind.
But it isn't easy.
The first time I was here
was with Eisenhower in 1953.
He was a different kind
of man than you find now,
the last president to be
born in the 19th century.
He knew things almost
nobody knows now.
He remembered waking
up at dawn to pray
to ancient gods of
small-town Texas.
He told me a lot
about the war, things
that no one should ever know.
He said that he wasn't afraid
of the future, only the past.
I put my jacket back
on, thinking ahead
to what would be in that
room on the eighth floor
of the Watergate Hotel--
chairs pushed to the walls,
perhaps a dead man
in a wool suit seated
in the lotus position in the
exact center of the room.
It would be freezing inside--
outside, the heat of a June
night, packing crates
marked in Cyrillic letters,
a scattering of black feathers.
The Cubans would do their part.
Afterwards, the
cleanup and the set
dressing, staging the next act.
They'd be found and
the police summoned.
The team would be
revealed as amateurish
hired hands caught
in the wrong place--
the coverup behind the coverup
Liddy would do his comic turn
as the loose cannon.
History would take its turn.
And my public life
would begin to unravel.
But I survived.
I outlived the hippies.
I outlived Elvis and Marlene
Dietrich and the Soviet Union
itself.
It's been 20 years
now since I was
forced to stage my own death.
The tiny silicon disk on
the moon that bears my name
is slowly gathering dust.
I lived on to see myself become
a laughingstock, a cartoon
villain-- that place in the
August roll call of presidents,
where history
pauses and snickers.
This is a story of the
great con game that
was the late 20th century,
of American history's worst
presidency, of how
I learned to lie.
It is not history
as you know it.
Suffice it to say that
there are at least
three sides to this story, and
I will be telling both of mine.
I promise you, I will
show the same contempt
for the historical record
that it has shown for me.
My name is Richard
Milhous Nixon.
I swore an oath to preserve,
protect, and defend
the Constitution.
I was educated at
Whittier College
in Whittier, California.
And I have seen the devil walk."
And that is Chapter 1.
And I thought I would
say a few words,
because the first interview
question I ever encounter
on this book is
why I would choose
to write about Richard Nixon,
our uncanniest president.
And there are several answers.
For one thing, he was
our funniest President,
I have to say.
I liked writing about Nixon.
He's one of those people where
if you put him in any context,
he's still funny--
in the grocery store,
at the laundromat.
He's always funny.
And I thought, what if he was
a paranormal investigator?
That was the best
context I could possibly
think of for a Richard
Nixon character.
So the book has
two major elements.
Well, it's split a couple ways.
It's split between
as accurate a staging
of the historical
record as I could do,
and then a behind-the-scenes
story which, as I said,
involves a supernatural
conspiracy in a fairly H.P.
Lovecraftian cosmos.
Because again, what was the
funnest thing I could do,
I asked myself.
Does this work?
It does work.
OK.
That's Nixon.
I couldn't tell writing
the book, I have to say,
if people would actually
know who Richard Nixon was.
If you ever teach in a college,
you realize that, like, it's
not clear always whether
freshmen have a grasp of who
Bill Clinton was, to say nothing
of Communism and the Soviet
Union, I have to say.
I was born in 1969, which is
just in the dim, dim past.
Nixon was the President
when I was born-- maybe
for some of you as well.
He was one of the first
public figures I was aware of.
And that posed the question,
because when I was, like,
five years old, I was
trying to make sense
of what the adult world was
like, or what made sense
and how it ran.
And so I was aware of
Richard Nixon, very,
very vaguely, as the top guy.
He was number one in the
adult hierarchy of everything.
But I was also aware that
he was a complete joke
and that everybody hated him.
Because it was '74, '75.
And that began my journey
into the conundrum
of the grown-up world.
And trying to make sense of
it, it was a stumbling block
that I've never quite
gotten over, because what
the hell was going on?
So that was really
why I dived into this,
to figure out the conundrum
or the secret of Nixon,
which is in some way the secret
of the adult world to me.
Because we only see him
through hindsight, right?
almost a footnote at this
point and in history.
And he's a joke
and he's a villain.
But if you actually step
back to see his life,
you see how weirdly huge it was.
He was born in 1913.
He died in 1994, allegedly.
He was this huge national
figure from the late 1940s
to the mid or early 1970s.
He resigned in 1974.
So he kind of spans and in
some ways sort of authors
the political life
of the second half
of the 20th century in America.
There he is smiling about it.
I think that's when he
got elected to Congress.
So he was in at the beginning
of Cold War paranoia.
That's him at the
Alger Hiss trial,
one of the early high profile
trials for treason for people
for Communist spying.
He sort of got in at the
beginning of the idea
that our friends and
neighbors could be
Communists and Communist spies.
And that put him on the
national stage politically.
At the beginning, he was a
little bit of a nonstarter.
But you can see that he had
this presidential grasp of what
the political culture would be.
And then he's Vice
President under Eisenhower.
So he spends eight years in the
White House during the 1950s,
at the heart of
things, at the heart
of the golden age, the
highway system, the beginnings
of the culture of the Cold War,
of the culture of brinksmanship
and containment and craziness.
He's in at the death of Stalin.
He's in at the hydrogen bomb
and all the crazy rapid response
stuff that gave us such lovely
drama as we were growing up,
waiting for the world to end.
That's him at the
Checkers speech,
with his completely
inscrutable wife.
He was losing.
He was going to get kicked
off of the Vice Presidential
ticket, and he just rented
a half hour of prime time
television and went on
completely without a script
and put his wife next to him and
talked about his dog, Checkers.
And today it's a
joke, but in fact it
was an enormous
political triumph.
Pat is the other major
character of the book.
And if there's anybody we know
less about their inner life
in American history
than Nixon, it
is Pat Nixon, who was a
complete mystery to this day.
The only good anecdote
I have about Pat
is-- actually what an
interviewer told me,
because he had interviewed
George McGovern after.
And McGovern told
the story of after he
had lost the '72 election and
he was seated next to Pat Nixon
at a dinner.
And it was a little bit awkward.
He had been completely
trounced in the presidency.
And at some point, Pat
turned to him and said,
you know he's crazy, right?
I can't vouch for that
anecdote, but at least I'm
not the one who made it up.
At least somebody else did.
Anyway, Nixon careers.
He's the heir apparent to
the presidency in the 1960s.
Of course, he comes up
against John F. Kennedy,
who he didn't see coming.
He loses the popular
vote by 100,000 votes,
so one of the closest
margins in history.
And I'm just spelling out his
weird dominance in everything.
He was a political
outcast after that.
That's, I think, a still
from the Kennedy debates.
And I have to say, I think
most modern presidents
would avoid getting that
still taken of them.
But this was an earlier,
much more spontaneous era
in political television.
There he is having a complete
meltdown in 1963 after he
loses the gubernatorial race.
He has the brilliant
idea of going off
script in his concession speech,
and just completely trashing
the political journalism of
the time, in a totally out
of control way.
One of the things I love about
Nixon is that he's bizarre
and he's clearly just
barely holding it together
the entire time he's
in public, which
is again, one of the things that
made him great to write about.
But then he comes back, and in
1968, he wins the presidency.
He's exactly a
time-shifted Al Gore,
as if in 2008, Gore had come
back and just swept everything.
He beat Ronald Reagan.
He beat George Romney.
He beat Nelson Rockefeller.
Again, it's another complete
enigma in political history
that he was able to
come back and do that.
And this is the
thing that people
miss in hindsight,
because everybody
knows the post-1974 Nixon.
Everybody knows the
resignation and the disgrace.
People forget that people
absolutely loved Richard Nixon.
He was a beloved figure.
He grew up legitimately poor.
He was a populist.
He was a pragmatist,
which is to say he
had no moral center whatsoever.
But they loved him.
There's him bringing--
that's Dick Cheney and Donald
Rumsfeld.
And here's another weird quality
of him, which is that so much
of what he did is what
we got stuck with.
I have to say, so much of what
we have now, Nixon gave us.
He also brought George
Herbert Walker Bush.
I mean, these guys
were getting in anyway.
But Nixon was the one who
shook hands and welcomed them.
He gave us the space shuttle.
He pulled Roger Ailes
out of obscurity
in 1968, the
founder of Fox News,
and made him his media director.
He sort of founded the
hyper-scripted, symbiotic
relationship between
the Republican
Party and a national
news organization.
He got that going.
He gave us the space
shuttle, for better or worse.
When we did the Pluto
flyby, it totally
came out that we would
have had it a decade ago
if it weren't for Richard Nixon.
He's the kind of Forrest
Gump of American politics.
Like, once you look for
him in that entire era,
he's absolutely everywhere.
And by '72, he's one of the
most recognizable members
of our species on the
entire planet, which
is what makes it so bizarre
that in a couple of years,
people were going to
realize that nobody ever
had any idea who he was.
He was the sort of
cranky introvert.
Almost nothing he said in public
was in any way uncalculated,
except when he
completely lost his shit.
And after a moment,
you could see it.
Like, as far as we
can tell, we can only
tell two things about him.
One was that he really,
really hated people who
went to Ivy League colleges.
Like, he just-- he hated what
he saw as the New England
aristocracy.
He was from Orange County.
And like I said,
he was legit poor,
which is one of the few
things you can say for him.
And he really wanted
to be President.
That's the other thing
that we know about him.
Like, if there's any passion
we can detect in his life,
that's the one.
And he clearly got
in way over his head.
He clearly could
not handle whatever
it was that was going on.
I like to think of him as a
kind of patron saint of impostor
syndrome.
Because he was totally
unfit for whatever it was he
got himself doing.
Because the crime itself,
the Watergate break-in,
made no sense whatsoever.
He sent people, or sent
people to send people,
however far the
chain goes, to break
into the Democratic
National Committee quarters
and steal some papers.
He got nothing for that.
He got nothing for that
and he won the '72 election
in a landslide, regardless.
Brought down his entire
presidency for nothing.
And for somebody who
obviously had the ability
to calculate
politically, it makes--
it's a profound
piece of nonsense
that for me, it needed
to be explained.
What was going on in there?
And for somebody who almost
never sort of showed their hand
in public, was there
even a person in there,
as we understand it?
I wanted to show a
short-- that's sad Nixon.
He's doing his resignation.
But he's fine, obviously.
There's absolutely no reason to
feel sorry for Richard Nixon,
because he was, among other
things, a horrible person,
which is not how I wrote him.
But I just wanted
to-- to some degree,
part of the challenge of this
book was to vindicate Nixon.
I came up with it roughly at
peak Lincoln versus vampires,
when that thing
was a whole craze.
And I thought to myself,
well, that's not a hard trick,
making Lincoln a big hero.
What would be a hard trick?
What would be the hardest
trick with a President?
It would probably be Nixon-- not
our worst President, but very,
very close.
I'm not going to go
into Andrew Jackson.
Let's not do that.
No, that's Nixon.
That's a rare Nixon by
himself moment, I have to say.
And that's more how I
think of him, just this guy
by himself, trying
to figure out,
what the hell is my next
move-- and profoundly isolated.
Because if you're Richard
Nixon, who exactly
do you trust with all your shit?
This is a very brief video clip.
And I wonder if we can show
this from 26 seconds out.
This is the famous-- I probably
can play this without audio.
This is the famous "I
am not a crook" moment.
This is in 1973, I think.
He's well into the
impeachment proceedings.
He's doing a press conference.
He's actually standing in the
hotel at Walt Disney World.
And the Nixon-Disney
World connection
is, I have to say, by itself
incredibly fascinating
and gets some play in the book.
So if we can try to play
this from about 20 seconds,
this is where we
get the money quote.
Yes, he's building up to it.
I'm doing this
silently for a reason.
American people have got to
know whether the President is
a crook.
He is not a crook.
And right now, he just
realized he said the worst
thing he possibly can.
And he folds his arms.
And his body language, as
you watch the fuller clip,
just starts to go haywire.
Because he knows he has
committed the greatest--
I think he knows
immediately that he's
committed one of the greatest
political gaffes in history.
Because again, he's
totally improvising.
He nearly always improvised.
He would start his--
when he was campaigning,
he started his campaign
speech by someone
going to introduce him
and he would make people
take away the podium,
just to show that he
was speaking without notes.
Because he thought people
cared about that, which
I think is one of the few
very touching moments,
was that he thought
people would like him
because he had a good memory.
So Nixon is in the
center of all of this.
And with his [INAUDIBLE].
I wrote a novel to explain that.
And the way I explained it was
by inventing a Lovecraftian
darkness to the Cold War that
becomes a conspiracy that he
discovers when he's
investigating in Alger Hiss.
And he just gets deeper
and deeper into it,
and he can never tell anybody.
Because one of the reasons is
that a pact with elder gods
is one of the keystones of
America's national defense
program in the Cold War.
Because if we would
build the hydrogen bomb,
we would make a pact
with Yog-Sothoth.
There's just no
question that we would
do that if we had had
the chance, because he
was so clear that we
would have done anything.
And once you catch
hold of that idea,
you kind of feel
inevitably you have
to start writing a secret
history of the whole business.
So the presidency isn't
what you think it is.
The Constitution isn't
And then there's
Nixon in the middle,
pretending that everything
is fucking normal.
He's pretending it to
the American public.
He's presenting it to his wife.
The only people he
can tell the truth to
are a pair of KGB agents who
he's not even supposed to know.
But they become
his best friends.
So the second element of the
novel is a character study.
It's what's it like to have
a terrible, terrible secret
and at the same time to be
in the brightest spotlight
any human being can be in.
And it's my attempt to
explain the darkness of Nixon
and what it would be like if you
were actually a normal person
to be in Nixon's
position, and then
to go through the
horror and then
actually to live on
through the humiliation.
Because one of the starting
points for this was,
what was it like to be
Nixon in 1975 or 1980?
And you're still there.
And everybody knows your face.
Everybody knows what you did.
Everybody has laughed at you
and is still laughing at you,
and thanks to
"Saturday Night Live"
is just going to keep laughing
at you, for basically forever.
And the second-- I'd like
to thank Google Image
search for letting me put
this presentation together
about a half hour ago.
So that's the image I
took of Nixon-- Nixon
by himself on the
phone, kind of shadowy,
frantically trying to, say,
send some secret message
to somebody.
And in my imagination,
what he's saying is,
get me the hell out of this.
Whatever the hell I've
done, I need help.
So I decided to let him talk
about it in his own voice.
And so the second section is
from-- I think I set it in '83.
So this is actually part of the
coda, the political afterlife
of Nixon.
And he's going to one of
his-- I made this part up.
He's going to one of his first
public speaking engagements
since-- it's well
after Frost/Nixon,
but it's one of his
first public speeches
as he's trying to come
back into political life,
because he thinks he can.
He thinks he can.
He came back in '68.
He thinks he can not
run for President,
but be a sort of statesman.
So he's going to speak.
"They led me in by
a side entrance.
They took me through quiet
corridors to a steel door.
I could hear the hum and
chatter of the excited crowd
as the mayor went in and gave
them one last reminder of who
they were about to see.
And she told the story well.
The Environmental
Protection Agency, Title IX,
peace in Vietnam, detente,
the voyage to China.
And then as usual,
a slight faltering
through the last bits, edging
past the salient details
like a man on a narrow ledge.
And then please welcome our
37th President, Richard Milhous
Nixon.
I squared my shoulders
and made my entrance,
walked solemnly to the
lectern on the podium.
There was a hush as I looked
out at the eighth grade
class of the Des Moines Martin
Luther King Jr. Middle School.
I saw Pat standing at the
back of the gymnasium,
watching it happen.
I let the silence
drop and settle,
breathed in and leaned forward
slightly to the microphone.
And then as I pronounced
the first syllable,
every non-adult
person in the room
began to yell at the
top of his or her lungs.
I was looking up into a
solid wall of gyrating arms
and bellowing faces and
children screaming at me.
I had miscalculated.
At first, I couldn't hear
the individual words.
But then, I didn't
need to, did I?
Every single
monstrous one of them
was in the same identical
pose-- arms locked
rigid overhead, second and
third digit of each hand spread
in an ecstasy of inspired
mockery, shoulders hunched,
shaking phantom jowls, all
shouting the same thing,
chanting it, saying it like
I'd never said it-- not crook.
I am not a crook.
Boys and girls, I began.
It was like speaking
into a high wind.
I stood stranded on
the podium, waiting
for the deluge to recede.
And if anything, it grew louder.
I looked down at the
cheap wood of the lectern.
I remembered other,
better lecterns.
Boys and girls--
I started again.
It just kicked them into a
higher gear, but I kept on.
It's an honor to be here at
Martin Luther King Jr. Middle
School.
It's truly marvelous.
I couldn't possibly
be any happier."
I've never learned to do
a Nixon voice, by the way.
But the guy who does
the audiobook kills it,
I have to say.
"I was once just like you.
I went to a small school
in Yorba Linda, California,
in a time long distance.
But my hopes and dreams
were the same as yours.
I worked hard.
And in 1946, I was
elected to Congress.
The sun was dying down a little.
In 1948, I was catapulted
to national-- "Tricky Dick!"
yelled a red-faced boy.
And the cry was taken up.
And near anarchy was again
loosed upon the gymnasium.
Boy wore a t-shirt with the
word "Supertramp" on it.
What the hell did that mean?
The principal hopped
onto the stage
and made as if to take
over, but I waved her off.
Down below, children
ran left and right,
and objects were
thrown, and offenders
were dragged from the room.
It was the Chicago
riots in miniature.
They had Richard
Nixon himself here,
and they were going to
make the most of it.
It's all right, I
told the principal.
They're just having
a little fun.
It wasn't her fault.
If I hadn't wanted
to be mocked by
young teenagers, I
could have protected and
defended the Constitution,
like I said I would.
You know, boys and girls, I like
a joke as much as the next man.
I really do, I said.
Politics is a tough
business, and you
don't get through
without it a thick skin.
It's not always easy.
I ran for Vice President
in '52 with Eisenhower.
We had our own trouble with
the Communists in those days.
Did eighth graders know
who Eisenhower was?
They had at least heard
the word "Communist"
as a sort of socialist goblin.
They were Reagan youth.
We faced great challenges-- a
nation divided, Soviet Union,
spies, nuclear
missiles, the Cold War.
I groped for words.
What could I tell them?
What did these kids know?
I looked out into the
blank half-pubescent faces.
They knew Reagan, that
ignorant pretender.
They didn't know
Eisenhower or Stalin or me.
'For Christ's sake, I
was President,' I shouted
into the microphone
to a howl of feedback.
In the back of the
room, Pat winced
and made a slight
shushing motion
with a pale and trembling hand.
But I wasn't done.
Who knew the truth now?
No one but her and
Kissinger, a creature
so far from human as
to scarcely matter,
a being who might
never die at all.
I had to tell them the story.
Your mothers and
fathers voted to make
me their supreme leader,
the most venerated position
an American can aspire to.
Laugh if you want
to, but believe it,
you little shits, I was
your fucking President.
When had the crowd gone silent?
I heard the last
words ring three times
through the gymnasium,
like Peter denying Jesus.
And all at once,
I understood them.
At their age, I didn't even know
what a President was, really.
It was the people of our
country decided who was the best
person in all of America.
And that person got
to make the decisions.
And I, the boy they had
one day called Tricky Dick,
wanted to be that person.
God, I wanted it.
I cannot tell a lie.
I don't know why.
I just did.
So I knew why they
were laughing.
I'd taken the idea
of the presidency
and I'd turned it into a joke.
And it's not that
it wasn't funny,
because whatever else I am, I
am history's funniest president.
But these children
were laughing at me
to turn the thrust
of a disappointment.
They were laughing
because I had hurt them
in a very personal way.
I was President the year
they were born, the President
their parents gave them.
The best person in America
turned out to be me.
And they were still
trying to laugh me off.
After I signed the
letter of resignation,
Pat and I walked to a
waiting helicopter clutching
our suitcases like newlyweds.
And the concrete chambers
beneath the White House
were then sealed forever.
I am the last chief
executive ever
to have seen them or
practiced the vile sorceries
to which they gave me access.
I looked at Pat.
She shook her
head, no, leave it.
The Cold War was a lie, and
far beyond the Iron Curtain,
the blacked-out science
city lay frozen and empty.
There are truths so
awful they can't be told,
and words so dense and alien
and maligned that they take 18
and 1/2 minutes to say and even
digital tape cannot reproduce
their accursed sounds
The rooms of the sealed chamber
hold all these truths, last
and least among
them that once I had
wanted to be President, defender
of the republic, the true one
that was promised
long ago, holder
of the highest office in all
the land, even if I am a crook."
That's the end of Nixon.
I can do a little Q and
A or talking about Nixon.
When I'm at a cocktail party and
I mention I write about Nixon,
anyone over a certain
age-- although they
don't have to be--
has something,
something to say about Nixon.
I have to say it's weird.
It brings something to
the surface in a way
that I find entertaining
and a little poignant.
Oh, I forgot to say, also
director of design at a company
called Magic Leap, which Google
put an enormous amount of money
into.
And that's a weird
coincidence and I
can't say anything about it.
Anyway, question?
AUDIENCE: I was a senior in high
school in '94 when Nixon died.
And I remember
reading the obits,
and I was just flabbergasted
that he was set forth
as this elder statesman that
everybody should listen to
and every new President
took the counsel of.
I'm just curious if you have
any of your own insights
into how he went from
being a total laughingstock
to having nice obits.
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: Everybody
went to that funeral
with a totally straight face.
Everybody acted super solemn.
I just assume it was because the
political culture just couldn't
assimilate the facts of Nixon.
And they just found it better
to go into denial mode.
They were trying to retrieve
the presidency for themselves.
Bill Clinton was there, gave
a very good touching talk.
They just couldn't admit
that Nixon had fucked it up
for them.
That's my theory there.
They were just trying
to hand wave themselves
through the whole matter.
In the book, Nixon
watches it on TV
and he dies laughing,
practically.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry to
change gears here,
I read "Soon I Will Be
Invincible" last year,
and I was curious to hear the
origin story of that book,
same as how you're describing
how "Crooked" came about.
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: That has
an origin story, as it were.
"Soon I Will Be
Invincible" is about what
it's like to be a
supervillain-- basically what
is it like to be Lex Luthor.
What is it like on the inside?
What is it like when you go
home and have to make yourself
breakfast in your
secret fortress?
I have to say-- I mean,
that was my first book.
I wrote it when I was in grad
school, when I was supposedly
going to be an
English professor.
It's about a lot of things.
It's probably about being
a graduate student, where
everyone tells you
how smart you are
and then they just
totally step all over you.
It's about just the
infuriated feeling
that you're incredibly
smart and the world
is just laughing at you.
And it's was also about
getting up in the morning
and doing it again.
Because any supervillain
is like Wile E. Coyote.
They come back, and they think
it's going to work this time.
And that was, for
me, an affirmation
of the human spirit.
And also because no one was
going to write-- at the time,
no one was going to
write "Watchman" again.
I just wanted to
read more "Watchman"
and I was going to
have to write it myself
if it was going to happen.
And then of course they
did, which is even sadder.
Question?
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
This may ramble for a bit.
Sorry.
One of the cool
things about Nixon
is that even those of us who
grew up after the whole thing
happened, we still have
those cultures from the time,
from the '60s, from the
'70s, that refers to Nixon,
it feels so alive
today still to me.
I love how you
imagined his character
and imagined you got inside
his head in the book.
I saw Stephen King
recently in the "Times"
for some reason slamming
the book "Our Gang," which
I read and thoroughly enjoyed.
And that was another fascinating
way to get inside Nixon's head.
Do you know "Our Gang"?
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: I know of
it, but I didn't read it.
It's one of those books
where you're writing a book
and you keep away
from it, because you
don't want your imagination
to become contaminated.
But I know what it is.
I didn't hear a question.
AUDIENCE: Kind of rambled
a little bit, didn't I?
Just thinking about how cool it
is that all this culture still
exists about Nixon
from that time
and how it seems like it's still
alive and could be just kind
of grabbed and
accessed immediately.
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: Well, I know.
And I was wondering about that.
Did people forget Nixon or not?
But apparently they didn't.
I mean, he's the
American Lex Luthor.
I There's something about
his massive public fuck-up
that people like to
hang on to, I guess.
Like, you're never going
to have a worse day,
perhaps, than
Nixon did, I guess.
And I think maybe because people
secretly think or know that all
our presidents are crooks.
But one of them admitted it.
And it's just a
continuing relief,
at least maybe that's
how it is for me.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
I might be standing too close.
Sort of a serendipitous moment
here-- you talk about the book
and I hadn't heard
about it until I
started seeing the posters.
My wife right now is reading
"One Man Against the World,"
which is a Tim Weiner book.
I was curious in specific,
if you were aware
of that book and the timing,
because it's pretty well timed
for you, I would think.
And then also, a
lot of the stuff
that's revealed in that
book, I haven't read it.
She's like, every
night turning over,
like, did you know--
one of these things.
I mean, the amount of
drinking Nixon was doing.
Those types of facts-- I'm
curious, where you aware
of that?
And then just in
general, where else
did you take research
from around some
of the real meaty
historical stuff?
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: The more
facts you read about Nixon,
the more you realize
that he didn't
have any of the
political discipline
that a contemporary
president has.
Yes, he drank like crazy.
He would drink and
make crazy phone calls.
If a modern President tried
to do the things he did,
he would have five advisors who
would tackle him to stop him.
I mean, the example
is after Kent State,
all these protesters are lined
up on the Lincoln Memorial.
Hippy kids are
just camped there.
And Nixon drinks until 4:00 am.
And then he goes out in person
onto the Lincoln Memorial
to talk to them.
Like, he just walks
across the lawn.
Can you imagine a contemporary
President just drunkenly
mingling with the
protesters and nobody--
they would hit him with a
tranquilizer dart or something.
They would just stop it.
At least he was--
there are moments
when you can detect
a human being who
is just willing to fuck up.
And again, it's a
little sad that we've
lost that, I have to say.
Anyway, it's weirdly
the summer of Nixon.
There were, like, two or
three books that came out,
not even counting mine.
And I'm not sure
why that is, other
than people who
were born with Nixon
are old enough to
write books now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: There you go.
Someone did research.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
after Reagan and Hinckley,
[INAUDIBLE].
AUSTIN GROSSMAN:
That's a good point.
It's a weird sea change
when Reagan came in,
the more you look at it.
Anyway, the book I read for this
was called "Nixon Agonistes"
by Gary Wills.
And it's a terrible
title, but I really
think it's one of the
most brilliant piece
of political journalism
I have ever seen.
There's a great scene where
he's on the plane with Nixon
as he's campaigning.
And he talks to Nixon,
but everyone's sleeping
so the lights are kind of out.
And he talks to Nixon
and he's talking
and he can't see Nixon's face.
And suddenly, he
realized when you're not
staring at Nixon's face, he
becomes a totally different
person, because the hypnotic
jowls and nose armature just
turns him into a character.
But when you can't
see his face, it
feels more like
talking to a person.
Anyway, it's a great book.
It may be out of print.
I'm not sure.
I had to special order it.
I did a bunch of
research, but I'm never
going to be the guy who
has the-- I did what
felt like the right
amount of research
so that I could then start
making stuff up from there.
I'll put it that way.
Every once in a
while, I deviated
from the historical
record here and there.
The night of Watergate,
Nixon was in the Bahamas,
or his body double was.
We don't know.
And then I actually
transferred some
of the rides between Disney
World and Disneyland.
And actually, the biggest
pushback I've gotten
is messing with some of
the details of Disney World
versus Disneyland.
Make of that what you will.
Did you know that
in the early '60s,
they wouldn't let
Khrushchev into Disneyland?
He wanted to go, and they
were like, no, no, you can't.
What were they hiding?
AUDIENCE: So in the book,
some of the presidents
know about the
supernatural activities
and some of the other
presidents have no idea,
or they only suspect.
How did you decide which
presidents would be in the know
and which ones
would be ignorant?
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: Well,
it came out weird.
The idea is that at the founding
of the Plymouth colonists
and then the founding of
the proper United States
becomes a sort of magical
pact with the native elder
spirits of the
continental United States.
And that certain powers
and responsibilities
devolve onto the president as
a kind of intrinsic element
to that contract.
But that knowledge is lost.
It's lost during the
Civil War and then
Taft kind of
semi-reconstructs it.
But part of what
happens to Nixon
is Eisenhower knows the
most about it of anybody
during the 20th century.
But in '57, Eisenhower
has a stroke.
And in the book, he
loses the knowledge.
So Nixon was supposed to be
briefed on what a sorcerer
president does.
But then he doesn't know.
He's left adrift.
It works out for some reason
that nearly all the presidents
in the know are Republicans.
And it was not on purpose.
It just worked out that way
that the Republican lineage
makes it the dominant
one, although I
will say it's not the
ideological Republicans
of today.
Eisenhower was--
and Nixon himself
was virtually completely
distinct of the Reagan
and post-Reagan Republican
to the point where he's
more or less unrecognizable.
But yes, it just ended
up being the Republicans
because-- it ended up being
passed down within one party
and that ended up
being the Republicans.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is more of
a cocktail party.
So I moved into the States
from Dominican Republic in '74.
I was around 12.
And I have to say, it
was a loss of innocence
to realize that US politics,
as perfectly portrayed
in movies and so on, was just as
corrupt as Dominican politics.
AUSTIN GROSSMAN: [LAUGHS].
Oh.
Well said.
But again, it was
always corrupt.
He just forced us
to acknowledge it.
I mean, Warren G. Harding
was really the-- Teapot Dome
Scandal.
I mean, Harding was really
just as bad, if not worse.
He just didn't have
the charisma to get
in trouble the way Nixon did,
is my only theory on that one.
If there's nothing else,
we can totally wrap up.
I'm going to hang around
and have lunch and all that.
I'm happy to talk to people.
Thank you guys for coming
out in the middle of the day.
This was great. [APPLAUSE]